good afternoon and welcome to this live
discussion from the european parliament
here in strasbourg today we are going to
talk this information and foreign
interference in the european union i'm
robert from the social media team of the
european parliament and to discuss about
this job subject i'm joined by rafael
glicksman who is a member uh chairing
the committee uh that the parliament set
up to assess actually the level of
threat and uh proposed solution to
counter these attempts uh to undermine
democratic processes in the union thank
you very much for joining this live
discussion welcome thank you for the
invitation i'm very glad to be here with
you i'm very glad that you are here uh
because uh we want to to ask a lot of
questions to you about
uh what this information is especially
in these times where it's really really
important to address these issues uh
with
the pandemic and the war in ukraine the
european union is more than ever
affected by this and i want all our
viewers to ask their questions if they
have any in the comments section on
youtube and on facebook and i'll try to
ask as many as i can to my guest mr
glueckman's you uh had a first mandate
of this special comedy that the
parliament set up what does this um and
then now you're granted a second one but
i want to talk about the first mandate
and uh how set uh the stage a little bit
for us how has it been like uh so far
and what were the main conclusions of
the first mandate of this committee so
first we wanted to create a specific
committee in the european parliament to
establish a diagnosis on foreign
interference in our democratic processes
because the feeling was that
actually we we had information coming on
interference of russian government
during one election during a referendum
for instance during the brexit
referendum or we had
all witnessed how some of former head of
governments from europe were going to
work for gaspon in russia or for huawei
in china and we all knew that there was
this uh
troll factories in saint petersburg
attacking our public debates through
social platforms but there was never a
general diagnosis on how big the threat
is and how much uh foreign interference
have an impact on our democratic life in
europe so we wanted to establish this
diagnosis and since once the diagnosis
is established we want
to make changes basically that's the
idea of being here so
we have set up many recommendations
going from the regulation of social
platforms to the harmonization of laws
all across europe on the
on the funding of political parties or
i mean
very very large spectrum of
recommendation and why we have created a
new one is because we don't want it to
be a one-shot what we want to do is to
follow if our recommendations are
implemented and to prepare
2024 elections that will be clean from
foreign interference and by
implementation you mean not only the eu
institutions but also looking into
loopholes on the national level as well
of course i mean you know it's always
the same problem we have 27 different
legislations 20 for instance if you take
funding of political parties 27
different rules and the problem is that
if you want to create a common european
space you need to harmonize rules and if
you want european elections to be really
european with the european debate and
and i mean you have seen you i'm sure
you have seen the parliament has voted
for the transnational list for instance
and then you need what you need a common
protection
for this political space all across
europe so a big part of our work has
been to look into the loopholes the
differences between
approaches
in malta or in france for instance and
how you can
have conversions there and and make sure
that we all play according to the same
rules because if you are sitting in
moscow or in beijing
of course you are making the same
analysis as we are making here and you
are looking at the loopholes and you
invest these rupauls and you managed to
have an influence that you should not
have over public debate in europe
uh and they have had the influence there
there have been many debates on this you
mentioned the the the elections uh uh
the europe election also also the
aftermath of brexit uh where we were
first like um
first confronted with this issue um
talk to me a little bit about the
tactics in general that i used to to to
saw uh discord in the
especially in europe but everywhere
where you know democracies healthy
democracies uh um
are so you have different actors and
they have different strategies and uh we
have worked during 18 months to analyze
what was their strategy and and what
type of actors were used and and what
was the impact so for instance if you
take the two big players in uh in
foreign interference in europe i mean
russia and china they have a different
approach
the chinese strategy is much more
classical in a way they want to buy your
infrastructure to make sure they control
your country it happens in
in greece or in portugal for instance or
not in the eu but in montenegro and
they have a classical approach they buy
infrastructures they buy politicians
they they buy
influence
through
cultural elites or economic elite
russians have
brought the
traditional interference to a whole new
level and a whole new strategy has
emerged it's what we have called the
strategy of cows so basically
you are uh
in the in in the russian regime what you
want is not so much to have friends in
in charge of european governments but to
have cows in europe and how does that
manifest for instance i will be very
concrete
in spain yes they will support the two
most opposite forces you can imagine
they will approach the independencies
from catalonia and they will approach
the nationalists from vox
i mean you cannot find most opposite
forces in in spain but they will support
both they will try to support both in
order to
polarize the debate so much that
institutions will be weakened and weaken
and we can till the collapse and that's
the idea everywhere so they can support
far left and far right at the same time
and it's something that's that's really
efficient in this world of social media
because anything that is polarizing the
debates is actually
working
on social media and so they will use
this new space of debate in order to
make our society more and more polarized
and to
raise the
mistrust in uh in institutions at the
national level and at the european level
you mentioned the european level we are
the european parliament you are a member
of this parliament do you see these
tactics being uh used also on the in the
european parliament
although this committee we must say has
had an overwhelming uh measure minority
yes but we have seen how much the far
right was opposing the creation of our
our committee and then uh the findings
of our committee are the measures
mentioned in your recommendations
we have for instance measures on the on
the
on the political funding of
coming from foreign regime and we have
all witnessed how much russian regime
has spent money and invested the
influence in order to support anti-eu
populists far rights movements all
across europe and it's not just one
party it's everywhere in europe you have
this uh russian footprints when it comes
to a populistic far right and
here in the european parliament we have
issues of even security of debates
thanks to uh far right being the
enablers of russian interference if you
take the example for instance of a
lady that has
really made her news here is tamara
volorova who was the advisor of the
group id
and she was directly reporting to the to
the
to the russian embassy whatever was
discussed in the cd committee so can you
imagine we can discuss
you and me we are sitting in a committee
at weak law and we discuss
i don't know like
weapons delivery to ukraine
and you have somebody
who is taking notes and then reporting
to the russians and this is
really something that is made possible
by the lack of culture of security in
the european institution so we have also
recommendations from our report for the
european parliament to raise the
security awareness and the security
culture inside this building
um
coming back to to the tactics used how
do
can you come up with some examples of
how
ordinary people uh in the who don't have
like we're not too exposed to this and
are not very well informed about uh how
to to
distinguish
false information or misinformation from
from truth uh what are some tactics used
in this in our societies that's uh and
how can people uh be aware of that
so
you have
all encountered basically on twitter on
facebook on instagram well
you have all encountered uh
without knowing it
uh a russian interference
you have this troll farms in san
pedersburg and they raise
some profiles and then you interact with
them you can even have a fight
and and at the end of the day it's not
the profile that's described yes it's
somebody in somebody's book is writing
even me on my facebook account for
instance i have uh the troll army from
pregojin with an oligarch close to putin
coming from from san trafric mali and
suddenly they become experts in donbass
history you know and
you you understand that there are trolls
but
worse now is that
sometimes it's not even human beings
behind that it's a artificial
intelligence and uh we just had a
mission to riga
where we had uh
where we have experienced ourselves the
creation of uh fake
polymix on twitter on on facebook
through artificial intelligence you just
have a keyword you enter them and then
the computer writes for your text
and they have that and and you can't
notice it basically so what we need to
do is to
have a public awareness campaigns
media literacy education
is a big part of our focus
and take example draw lessons from
examples that do exist for instance we
had a mission the first mission of the
european parliament ever to taiwan
first official mission of course some
diplomats were a bit worried that it
would be looked at as a provocation by
beijing but actually we went there to
taipei because we wanted to learn from a
young democracy how they can build up
their democracy while resisting
to
huge
much stronger than here
interferences coming from mainland china
and and the lesson we draw from taipei
is that actually instead of closing
their system they open it up and they
created a really inclusive democracy in
which
citizens have a say in every debate and
every reform and they have a wall of
society approach that involves think
tanks journalists citizens and
government bodies in order to fight this
information campaign coming from china
and it works i mean we have seen that
and they are much much much in advance
compared to us i mean we are a bit
old-school compared to they
as we speak we're out school but we're a
rich continent
and the rich bloc
what are some of the loopholes in terms
of legislation that you have noticed and
needs urgent addressing
especially ahead of uh the eu elections
so ahead of the eu elections i will
insist
on the registrations that are already in
the tubes dsa dma how you regulate
social platform and what we are doing
here i mean for once we are a bit in
advance and i think that it's uh it's a
bit of terrain cognita and it's a new
territory it's a regulation of social
platforms but it's it's really
fundamental if you want to keep this
platform as a as an agora for for
shaping our public debate
then
political funding it's it's a huge issue
in europe and you have so many different
uh legislation that you need to have an
harmonization
then i would
that qualifies as foreign interference
politics of course and if you have if
you have a foreign regime
either through official structure or
banks or oligarchs with
perverting the big debate by investing
money in your public debate then then
then it's a huge issue for us and the
the third example i would take is elite
capture we have no
legislation as we speak now
that will prevent
a chancellor from germany was decided
the building of nordstrom
to go then and work for gastron
as mr schwader did
but then
how is it possible that we allow
companies that are hostile to our
principles and our interests like
gasprom to be the
i mean to provide our leaders with
golden pensions
this is not acceptable
and so we need to have some rules there
and you think that you'll find the
support in the parliament uh especially
on well in the parliament i will find
the support but i'm not sure i will find
the support in the commission or in the
council
but for sure in the parliament there is
an awareness now and and and this
feeling that
i mean
for a very long period we have acted as
if we didn't have enemies anymore that
history in its tragic dimension had come
to an end and what we have seen now is
that
tragedy did not end we are leaving a
tragic time and we have still enemies
and adversaries and very violent one and
so we need to protect our democracies
and we need to protect also this feeling
for citizens that they are protected
by their leaders and that when they vote
for somebody and he will take a decision
it will be
in the for the general interest of
his
people not for the sake of a foreign
company who promised him a contract just
after his mandate yes i mean this is a
bit problematic and and we have to act
against this
the war in ukraine has fueled more
disinformation campaigns as uh the
european external election service calls
them uh information manipulation
campaigns this is an evolved term now uh
for this umbrella term for me
misinformation disinformation
uh who are uh
how how do you see the situation and uh
oh what do you think about the eu ban of
russian outlets uh in the eu has that
somehow
helped to minimize the the
risks first let us be very clear
this ban was absolutely legitimate and
necessary because we are not speaking
about media you know media they have a
dermatology they have a code they have a
criteria of independence we were
speaking of
tools in the hand of a in the end of a
regime that was wasted
so they are part of putin's system they
are not medias and so it's perfectly
legitimate if you sanction individuals
if you sanction companies
banks
oil or gas companies
and
fake media or
outlets as you said yeah it is right
sounds uh then it's perfectly legitimate
but it's it will not circumvent uh
russian propaganda from entering the
public debate in europe because
it's useful
but their strategy was not based only on
sputnik or on
on
it was a
just a part a tiny part of their
ecosystem and what they're betting on is
more high level profiles and enablers in
european countries and it's much harder
to struggle against enablers because if
you have
a spanish french or
an italian
media that are used by the russian uh
regime to channel the propaganda and we
are
in much harder situation to to regulate
and to block so so that's that's that's
the thing then
i want to repeat it because i know that
there are some concerns in europe
we we don't want to create a ministry of
truth i mean if you want to believe that
the earth is flat
it's your absolute right i mean i will
be of course
disagreeing with you and a bit
finding that you might look stupid by
saying that the earth is flat but as a
legislator i will not enter into it
but if i find out that the foreign
regime is spending millions so that
my fellow citizens are believing
in numbers of millions that the earth is
flat then it becomes a
topic and a concern for the legislator
so we don't want to create a ministry of
truth but we want to prevent
foreign regimes to uh actually from
having a say in our public debates do
you believe that it's possible that the
near future
should be a package
of legislation uh
eu-wise that covers all of these areas
and that addresses specifically you know
cases of foreign interference but also
how
uh these actors uh
act actually in the european union and
how they should be punished because
often it's just small uh
yeah uh uh right you know i'm new in in
the parliament but i'm old enough to
understand that it will not be
one decisive package it will be several
packages but we will push for that and
that's why we created in j2 it's because
we don't want
executive branch and we don't want the
conceal to think
you know
okay parliament got excited
and then drops
the subjects which often happens in the
parliament you know you you get focused
on one topic you push very hard you have
a very strong political message but then
you switch to something else and that's
why i insisted that we will go on with
our committee until it's implemented i
mean we will follow up and we will
question question the concealed question
the commission and make sure that we
have a much more protected democracy in
europe than today
how can
well we see that big
actors
use um
disinformation campaigns to undermine um
democracies but not only in the eu also
outside of the eu according to to their
interests but what uh um
when it comes to allies especially
eastern neighborhood
partners
especially on the east of the european
union uh partners in the north african
region but also the partners our
partners in the western balkans which
are
candidate countries for for eu accession
uh what do you think
the eu's role should be in in
supporting and equipping uh we need much
more presence i mean we need to consider
that it's already our space they are not
members but it's our common uh space and
we need to protect it because
our absence as a load
and and the lack of clarity of european
objectives on the ground have allowed
russia and china to over invest
in these neighboring countries because
when you leave countries in a gray zone
then that's much easier for for russia
and china to enter and so
for instance i will tell you
in georgia
and the way they proceed is that they
target uh vulnerable groups you know i
was going to ask you this question it's
important in georgia there was never an
issue but about lgbti rights you know
like never and suddenly
you have demonstrations and people
getting out in the street to be the
pro lgbti uh activist
and we all wonder where did it come from
i mean for those who know this country
yeah it was never an issue
and and in fact what we have identified
is that
russians have invested money in websites
in a in a
specific hardcore far-right orthodox
groups and they have created this issue
out of nothing and then it became a big
topic leading to street violence and
identification of
lgbti rights eu european integration and
making it a a fight for the soul of
christian georgia
and
this is really shaped from the scratch
by by manufacturers it's totally
manufactured it was not a debate and
suddenly they invest money energy
knowledge
as they say themselves polytechnology
that's a russian word
on one topic and it burns suddenly the
streets of bbc
and we have the same happening in every
neighboring country and we have to fight
against that but for this you need to
give to these people a horrorism which
is european integration long term and a
clear strategy on the ground on what
kind of principles we are defending and
how much we are ready to invest on media
literacy on
on education and on other fields plus
another thing we need to
really work closely with them uh in the
in the defensive approach which is that
they have
for instance in moldova in ukraine
identified a lot of russian actors that
are also operating in uh in european
space and we have identified other
actors so we need to have a shared
defense system against
this information campaign coming from
moscow do you see also cooperation
between i believe there is between nato
countries which are not members some of
them are not members of the eu and eu
the eu
some of which countries are not member
members of yeah nato does have a system
to tackle hybrid threats yes do you have
a similar
well we are making and let's be honest
it's like the half
empty half full
glass
we are starting to have
uh a system that's that's
the basis are promising but we are not
the force right yeah yeah
we have a
i mean i just went to rigaso to the nato
stratcom uh
center and
and they really are
have a great knowledge on how to
identify and tackle this information but
we have also now at the eas
uh a union election service yes sorry um
when i speak the jargon
the foreign ministry of the yeah the
foreign history of the eu you know
so at the external action service we
have um
we have now units led by mr gulner with
with
really efficient on that but it's new
and it needs to grow
and uh until very recently we didn't
have anybody checking what china was
doing for instance and uh and now we
have but it's
it's a joint uh evolution and the more
the parliament puts pressure and raise
the profile of the topic the more you
have money invested in uh in this so
it's it's useful it's a direct response
to our work here
hopefully this will uh also uh
uh be um
find support in the european union
because it's important to have
mechanisms to to fight this information
but you know it's it's not only uh
public bodies that need to to invest
because actually when you take european
companies they are investing much less
than american companies on
cyber security
and
and the way the the
russian or chinese regimes are
conducting their attacks
they identify weakness and then they
have pirates doing it for them so it can
be perfectly also targeting
private actors and i ask for ransoms
and this is this is something that's
still
both in the private and the public
sector in europe
we are not there yet mentally first why
because we we are first we are slow
let's face it and second
well
we really believed in this idea that we
will not have enemies anymore who will
attack us we are nice i mean we have
social security systems we care for the
environment we are the european union we
love peace and everything so
we never
i mean
security was very far away from us
and
and we didn't listen for instance when
you had estonians or latvians or poles
coming to to us in western european
capital saying look the storm is coming
so we need to get ready and prepare nah
come on
i mean it's the ghost of your past you
are still like bleeding from a russian
occupation so you are worrying about
everything that's happening in moscow
but we we know putin he's not our enemy
he's not our adversary that was the
music that was
played in paris berlin madrid or or rome
has this perception changed in the time
now with the war in ukraine 24th of
february changed everything and we have
seen how much now
western european capitals care about the
findings of our committee because when
we have set up the committee of course
there was nowhere in ukraine but now
with invasion everybody understands that
okay so maybe we have an enemy after all
and maybe this enemy is dangerous so we
need to pay more attention but if you
take an example to
show you
in 2017
the condi uh presidential candidate
emmanuel macron
had a campaign and he was in a runoff
against my le pen who was a great friend
of vladimir putin and putin's regime
hackers attacked macron's campaign and
and produced what was called then the
macro leaks yes
and
these hackers
were identified
we all know they belong they belong to
the russian system
and what was the consequence
i mean you hack
just before the main election of
one of the main european country
and what is the consequence for that i
mean what did we do during five years in
paris to uh or in brussels to punish
those who perpetrated this
nothing so it's
i mean our nifety
has led russian to think and rightly saw
russian regime
that
it was the cheapest
investment possible i mean with a great
return you know you do something
you know you don't have consequences
and the money you need to invest in
order to destabilize the public debate
is very little compared to i don't know
what you invest in
in
infrastructure if you want to buy a port
or a bank
would you what other um
like just shortly briefly
are there other means of hybrid threats
that
people should be aware of except for
disinformation foreign interference
through financing
what are those threats that we need to
look uh for the future yeah
everything that technology makes
possible artificial intelligence yeah
artificial intelligence you will have
the deep fakes i mean i really
again i experimented that
and i i could not sleep at night after
because i thought okay so i can shape a
video of uh i don't know zelinski or
thunder lion taking drugs or something
and it looks
now
you still have technical
technical issues but it will look like
absolutely true or
this is maybe too big but
i make you say something that you didn't
say but it will look exactly like we
have this conversation now except that
you will say something really outrageous
and let's say i'm candidate to an
election
presidential election
three days before you make
a video and you are a russian agent and
you don't want me to win you make a
video of me saying really outrageous
thing or recognizing that i did
something totally illegal or whatever
and it will look absolutely like it's me
and then what what's happening so we
will have really to first have a
technical defensive line that's quite
powerful but also education
and and um
everybody will need to be used
to uh these uh techniques
and thinking critically yeah yeah that's
right
i mean you you you will need a lot of
investments in in
modern infrastructures but you you will
need also a return to philosophy lessons
and and try to raise our critical uh
spirit i mean
it's
it's it's really fundamental because we
will be
more and more surrounded with
really hard to detect
fake information
absolutely i uh before coming here i got
a call from
some stranger with a belgian number
telling me that my national id has been
hacked and it's been used for criminal
purposes for a second i believe that too
so which means that people still tend to
believe yes
when you see it it's even more uh
real let's say yeah of course it's even
more difficult and if you have an
already polarized society and you
already
strongly dislike mr draghi
and then you have mr dragon and yes of
course you you will see it as a
confirmation of what you always believed
in so you will share it and then it will
spread
so it it's it's and how much time you
know every time you have to deny
a fake news
i mean for for your denial to penetrate
in the public opinion
it's very long while the spread of the
fake is very quick
so it's it's really
it's
it's uh
it's dangerous we live in a dangerous
world for sure yeah and
i hope that somehow you answered the
question of victor from youtube who says
should it be a subject in european
schools to study information gathering
on democratic self-defense i don't know
for sure
for sure it starts in school and the
more we will be familiar with uh with
the social platforms the technology is
the
the
the more
we will be immunized because what we
have
it's like vaccine in fact we need to get
vaccinated and for that we need to know
the the the field
on which we will have the debate there
and we need to understand this this uh
this world in which virtuality and
reality will be mixed
and
what we have seen also in our studies is
that
young people
who are supposed to be more targeted
because closer to to the virtual world
are in fact
less buying
the fake news campaigns because they're
already used to it and and
so we need to have a
real education from school
to
way after school because
people who are already pensioners they
still vote they still have a very
important and they have social media and
they also use facebook like the other so
uh
we need to have a permanent education
but yes on school for sure and we it's
part of our recommendation i mean we
need to have
programs in school on this
thank you very much this is this has
been most uh
interesting and i hope we'll have you
back to talk about the work of your
special committee on
foreign interferes and disinformation in
the year we can have a meeting before
europe and elections
and i will tell you if
various governments in europe or the
commission took all the measures that we
asked in order to make this election
safe and really european absolutely
we'll ask those questions is an
important milestone not just for the
european parliament but also for for uh
eu citizens thank you to everyone who
has followed this and for the cinema
lovers don't forget to join us on
wednesday at 2 p.m where we will talk to
the winner of the parliament's field
prize looks awards so uh stay tuned
until then thank you